in this video you're going to learn how
to work with the law of sines and the
law of cosines so when do we use the law
of sines in the law of cosines well it's
when we don't have a right triangle we
don't have that 90-degree angle so for
the law of sines there's two different
ways to write the formula you can either
write at this top one or this second one
here and let's talk about law of sines
first each problem I'm going to show you
I'm going to do two of sines and two of
the law of cosines each one's a little
bit different so you're gonna want to
see each example when we're given a
triangle let's just call it a generic
triangle ABC
notice that the capital letters are used
to denote the angles and then the
lowercase letters are used to denote the
side lengths and notice that here's
angle a across from angle a a side a
across from angle B a side B across from
angle C a side C and when we do the law
of sines I like to use this top equation
here you can think of this ratio the
sine of angle a over its side opposite
that ratio is equal to the sine of angle
B over its side opposite and that's
equal to the ratio of sine of angle C
over its side opposite so you only need
to use two of these three ratios to form
a proportion and then you can solve for
the missing quantity what I like to
think of is I like to think of the angle
and the sight across is like a pair so
you've got a pair a pair and a pair like
that so let me show you the first
example like say here we want to find
the measure of angle C well what I
notice first off is that I have 70
degrees and I have the side across from
that 70 degree angle I also have this
side here 6 and I'm looking for angle C
which is across from this side length of
6 so basically what we have is we have
two pairs and so we only have one
unknown quantity angle C so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say the sine
of 70 degrees over its side opposite
equals the sine of angle C over its side
opposite which is 6 now all we have to
do now is we need to get sine of angle C
by itself so I'm going to multiply both
sides by 6 that way the numerator
denominator cancel and then what we're
gonna do is solve for angle C is we're
gonna have to take the sine inverse of
this quantity let's do it one step at a
time though so first things first we've
got 6 times the sine of 70 degrees
all divided by seven and that comes out
to about 0.8 0-5 so 0.8 0-5 equals sign
of C if we want to solve for angle C
we're going to do the sine inverse of
0.8 0-5 and let's see what that comes
out to fifty three point seven degrees
so let's write that here are fifty three
point seven degrees and you got it
that's the measure of angle C now if you
want to proceed from there then you can
say well I know these two angles I can
subtract from 180 to find this angle I
could do law of sines again to find this
missing side and then you've solved the
triangle okay our second example using
the law of sines we're trying to find
this missing side right here X and again
what we want to do is we want to think
about the angle and the side across from
that angle as like a pair so here I've
got 50 degrees in ten here we have 35
degrees and X so we can use our law of
sines to solve for this missing in
quantity we've got 70 sine of 35 degrees
over its side opposite equals sine of 50
degrees over its side opposite and now
all we have to do is get this variable
by itself now what we can do is we can
cross multiply its x times the sine of
50 degrees equals 10 times the sine of
35 degrees now all we have to do instead
of multiplying by sine of 50 is divide
both sides by sine of 50 degrees that
gives us X by itself and we can
calculate that length so let's go ahead
and do that we've got 10 sine of 35
divided by sine of 50 make sure your
calculator is in degree mode since we're
working with degrees and it comes out to
approximately 7.5 and yeah the next two
examples we're going to talk about the
law of cosines we're gonna be working
with these three formulas here at the
bottom now if you know one of these
formulas you'll automatically know the
other twos so what I recommend is start
off by memorizing this top one C squared
equals a squared plus B squared
just like Pythagorean theorem minus two
times a times B times the cosine of
angle C one thing you'll notice about
these formulas is that see how this is
side C and angle C see how they're
across from each other or at opposite
ends in the formula just like they're
across from each other in the triangle
if we use this middle form of see side B
angle B they're across from each other
in the formula they're across from each
other in the triangle and we've got side
a and angle a and notice then if we're
working with this top one C C and C then
we've got a and B a and B if we're
working with me we've got a and C a and
C if we're working with a we've got B
and C B and C the other two that we're
not using right so when do we use law of
cosines that's the question a lot of
students ask well you can use the law of
cosines okay or you actually have to use
law of cosines when they only give you
three sides like side side side nothing
else or they give you side angle side
meaning the angles in between the two
given sides if you try to use law of
sines what will happen is you have too
many unknowns you won't be able to solve
because you've got like two variables or
more so that's when you use law of
cosines side side side or side angle
side let me show you example number
three here okay notice what we have
we've got side angle side that case I
was talking about right here we want to
find the side across from angle C side C
so we're going to use this top formula
here and let's go ahead and write it out
so we have C squared equals a squared
plus B squared minus two times a times B
times the cosine of angle C we don't
know what C is so let's just leave that
as a variable C okay a is the side
across from angle a that's eight squared
plus B that's the side across from angle
B that's ten squared minus two times
eight times ten times the cosine of
angle C which is 42 degrees now notice
how this is C squared here we just want
to solve for side C not C squared so I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take the square
root because the square and the square
root those are inverses they cancel if
we do that to the left side we also want
to do it to the right side so let's go
to our calculator let's put all that in
and we're gonna take the square root so
if you use parentheses you can do all
this in one step eight squared plus 10
squared let's see minus two times eight
times ten times the cosine of 42 again
make sure your calculator is in degrees
so that comes out to about six point
seven and you've got that missing side
okay example number four this is the
where you have three sides
side-side-side and you want to solve for
a missing angle in this case we're
trying to solve for angle B so what
we're going to do since we're trying to
solve for angle B let's use this middle
equation where we have side B but not
angle B and let's write that out so
we've got B squared equals a squared
plus C squared minus 2 AC cosine angle B
okay B is a side across from angle B
that's 15 squared a is a 1 across from
angle a that's 11 squared C is 1 across
from angle C that's 9 squared minus 2
times 11 times 9 times the cosine of
angle D now somebody students make a
little bit of arithmetic errors when
they're trying to solve for angle B here
so let me see if I can explain this
let's go ahead and simplify a little bit
here we've got 225 we have 121 plus 81
minus let's see 2 times 11 times 9 which
is 198 cosine angle B now what students
sometimes do is they try to combine
these numbers here you can combine these
but you really can't combine with this
because this 198 is multiplied by cosine
of via this is like all one group so
what we're gonna do instead is we're
gonna subtract 121 and we're going to
subtract the 81 we're gonna get them to
this left side of the equation so let's
do that now
so 225 minus 121 minus 81 so now we're
at 23 equals negative 198 times the
cosine of angle B we want to get cosine
B by itself
so let's go ahead and divide by negative
198 to both sides and let's see what
that comes out to okay so we're looking
at about negative point 1 1 6 equals
cosine of angle B now remember whenever
you're solving for the missing angle
that's when you want to do the inverse
sine or inverse cosine inverse tangent
like that
so the solver angle B we're going to
take the cosine inverse of negative
point 1 1 6 so let's go ahead and do
that and what I tend to do is I tend to
on my calculator use the previous answer
key so I take that long decimal so you a
little bit more accurate answer so it
looks like angle B here is approximately
ninety six point seven degrees and you
got it if you want to see more examples
what I didn't get into yet in this video
he
is when you're working with the law of
science you have a potential sometimes
to get one triangle two triangles or no
triangles depending on the information
that they give you so follow me over to
that video right there where I talk
about the ambiguous case using the law
of sines and I'll see over in that video